the Islamic Republic of Iran a country
where men enjoy far more rights than
women many women in particularly
well-educated ones leave the country
Tabassum Latif II would like to stay
she's established a startup in Tehran
and is determined to overcome all
obstacles and achieve success now after
the international agreement on Iran's
nuclear program many Iranians hope the
country will open up but can LUT if you
make it as a woman in a male-dominated
society
in a small Tehran side street logically
works hard every day in pursuit of her
goal her startup idea is called maman
pass it's an internet platform and a
mobile phone app that allows customers
to order home-cooked Iranian food with a
mouse click or a few taps on a
touchscreen the meals are then delivered
less if he enjoys being her own boss at
the tender age of 29 but not everyone
approves of her ambitions most Iranian
women don't work and they certainly
don't start their own businesses she
encountered resistance even within her
own family my mom told me don't do that
you that is nothing job he should do a
real job
you should go be a manager in some
company I don't know you studied so much
for I don't know like 16 years in the
school and university and you're very
good student and some something some
sort of things but they they didn't
believe my idea in a country where women
are often required to seek permission
from their fathers and husbands for
basic societal decisions family support
is essential in order to avoid problems
but latter if he was lucky to have one
committed supporter in her corner right
from the very beginning her husband me d
her to start this path because he was
not happy with her job at that time he
saw that he's not she saw that she's not
doing she she was not very useful in in
that job and I told I told her that at
least you
you may you may have a happier life less
if he quit her well-paid job at a bank
and went freelance throwing herself into
the deep end I have to have my own
business because I don't want to be to
be an employee and more employer I mean
anymore because you don't have enough
authority and everything to do whatever
you want to make a new thing that isn't
me that was not exist before
you want I wanted to create something
husband maybe also works for mum and
pass he has no problem with his wife
also being his boss behind every good
woman who might say is a good man it's a
labor-intensive business that if he is
heading to visit one of the iranian
housewives who cook for her food
delivery platform
mahiette is hard at work
but if he takes a look in her kitchen
the women who work for her have all
passed safety hygiene and health checks
and of course the food has to taste good
as well we're testing every food when
it's gonna be in the menu but some of
the foods are not so good enough and are
not as to a quality test of montage so
we have to tell the mom that these food
this food is not approved and this is
the this is the hardest part of our job
actually the hate has been approved her
food is delicious she's become a
favorite among Latta fees customers on
the menu today is mr. cha see me
eggplant spread now eat likes to cook
and she needed a job since my husband
died I've had to provide for myself so
at the start I applied for office jobs
but I soon noticed that cooking was more
my thing then I met mrs. Latifi and
heard about mom and paws the company
employs 29 other women in Iran as cooks
those women owe their jobs to Tabassum
Latifi so they're dependent on the young
entrepreneur that's a lot of
responsibility for a 29 year old Iranian
woman now he'd hastily Don's a headscarf
and hangs over the attractively packaged
food to a young man
he texts his motorcycle that's the only
way to get through the heavy traffic in
the Iranian capital it's no accident
that the delivery boy is a man women are
allowed to drive in the Islamic Republic
but not motorcycles before her next
appointment lat if he takes the
opportunity to meet with two friends in
Tehran s most famous Park the park in la
ley
it's no Aces have come in the disorder
of the Iranian capital in the partial
privacy of the park different rules
apply then out in the open on Tehran's
streets the park is a place where
laterthey and her friends can speak
openly it's been a while since they've
seen one another one of latter pees
friends lives in Canada she's one of
many young Iranian women who have
emigrated in search of a better
education greater job opportunities and
more freedom but Latif he says she's
staying put
I prefer to continue my life in Iran I
love living in Iran I just want like to
go visit other countries as a tourist
that's it I don't like living in other
countries for a long time because I I
like people speak Farsi in here and I
love Iranian food everything I I like
moving on with my family my friends my
with this culture at the same time she
intends to continue her career lat if he
aims to show that women too can make
their mark in Iranian commercial life
she's trying to address one of her
potential shortcomings she's attending a
cooking course LAT if he admits she
doesn't cook at all well yet she has to
know what good cooking is in order to
evaluate her own products but it's not
easy the young entrepreneur has a lot on
her plate
the authorities in Tehran aren't used to
dealing with businesses like hers so
they have a lot of questions people are
selling products to each other and we
are just in this in the middle of this
thing and there is there aren't any kind
of permission right now for this kind of
business but we are trying to make this
whole way for the others maybe for us
and for the others after after
the work of a pioneer is never easy
Latta these days are long and sometimes
even longer depending on Tehran traffic
tonight she's staying at home with her
husband Mehdi
Latif he says she doesn't spend much
time pondering questions like whether
it's much harder for her as a woman to
start a company in Iran than it would be
for Mehdi as a man if you're not you're
not ambitious enough you can't you can't
be a really really successful person
because you need to work so hard and try
to reach your targets your objectives if
you don't have peacock objective you
can't reach to lower objectives so you
have to think big and start small and
try to get there this is just the
beginning for Tabassum Latifi with the
international agreement on Iran's
nuclear program she may be able to
attract foreign credit and investment
and be able to expand she says the first
potential partners have already gotten
in touch
you